This paramecium is not having a particularly
good day.
You wouldn’t be either if the contents of
your body were being slowly consumed by a ciliate.
But as you, hopefully, are watching this from
a comfortable position, while not being consumed,
we would understand if your attention is diverted
from the microbial drama and instead focused
on all the shiny things, like looking down
on a city at night from an airplane, the moving
lights a sign of life at a distance.
These shiny colors are actually crystals,
visible this way under polarized light.
So, we have to use a special filter to get
these shots and they seem to be connected
to the paramecium’s metabolism.
We wanted to start with these crystals because,
like, we think they’re stunning.
And stunning is not necessarily the first
word that comes to mind when you think of paramecia.
Of the early microorganisms discovered by
scientists, paramecia have gone on to have
perhaps the most distinguished career.
Studied by scientists and students alike,
these protozoans have been so useful as a
model organism that one scientist called them
the “white rat” of ciliates.
But while paramecia have played an important
role in our understanding of genetics, microscopic
movement, and more, importance does not always
imply excitement or enthusiasm.
After all, if we compare paramecia to their
protozoan brethren, what does a hairy oval
have next to the shifting shapes of the amoeba
or the strange movements of the euglenoid?
That doesn’t stop paramecia from wanting
some attention though: there have been plenty
of times where we’ve set up a recording
of some beautiful organism, only to have paramecia
come by and photobomb our precious composition.
Their reliability in labs and frequent appearance
in classrooms might make paramecia seem like
a known quantity.
The things we know, we seem to have a good
grasp on.
We know that this is a paramecium, a unicellular
eukaryote covered in tiny hairs called cilia
that help it swim.
We know that when scientists first began describing
paramecia, they divided them into two groups
based on their morphology: Paramecium aurelia,
which have a long, tapered oval shape; and
Paramecium bursaria, which are shorter and
rounder.
We also know that they have multiple nuclei:
one macronucleus where transcription happens,
and a number of micronuclei that vary across species that become important during sexual reproduction.
We’ve talked about p aramecia in a previous
episode, describing the endosymbiotic algae
that reside inside of some species, providing
sugar produced through photosynthesis in exchange
for the movement and shelter of the surrounding
cell.
So much of their knownness rests on just how
widespread they are.
You can find paramecia in freshwater, brackish,
and marine environments around the world,
though the distribution, of course, varies
by species.
The ones that we’ve come to know best seem
to be the ones that are considered cosmopolitan,
that’s a word we use for things that are
found seemingly everywhere.
Recently, scientists studying Paramecium biaurelia
collected from 92 spots around the world over
62 years of time found very little genetic
variation between the different strains.
This kind of genetic similarity indicates
not only that these organisms have travelled
the world, but that they continue to, keeping
their populations spread out and not diversifying
into different species.
But the ubiquity that makes paramecia so known
to us is itself a question: how did paramecia
manage to find their way to all these different
locations, especially bodies of water that
are isolated from others?
Unlike some of the other aquatic organisms
we’ve discussed on this channel, paramecium
don’t form protective cysts that keep them
safe during a dry spell, which makes it that
much harder for them to cross the globe and
its many dry spots.
Through experimentation and observation, scientists
have confirmed the presence of hitch-hiking
paramecia on the wet fur of raccoons and on
the bodies of snails, showing that they might
be using the surface of animals as moist taxis,
but whether that explains the entirety of
their travels remains to be seen.
Paramecia are also subject to what you might
start to notice is a recurring theme when
it comes to the microcosmos.
While our early classification methods relied
on what we could see of an organism’s morphology,
the development of various molecular techniques
is uncovering new patterns and complications
in how we define the relationships between
its species.
These complications were hinted at by early
observations, like the fact that the broad,
morphologically-defined label of P. aurelia
couldn’t capture the strange mating subdivisions
that occured in the species, groups of P.
aurelia seemed reproductively isolated from each other.
In time, as scientists gathered more observations, P. aurelia stopped referring to one species of paramecia.
Instead, it was redefined as a complex of
fourteen siblings named P. primaurelia, P.
biaurelia, P. triaurelia…all the way up
to P. quadecaurelia.
And a fifteenth subspecies named P. sonneborni
was discovered later.
With more observation and genetic techniques,
the Paramecium genus has come to encompass
19 morphospecies, comprised of what are sometimes
called “cryptic species” these are species
who morphological similarities belie their
underlying differences.
When we look at them in the microscope, there
is no way for us to tell which species it is.
We would need to sequence their genome.
With words like “cosmopolitan” and “cryptic”
used as technical terms to describe paramecia,
they start to seem less like a textbook organism
and more like an international microbe of mystery.
It might be fitting then to learn from the
experience of the scientist Tracy M. Sonneborn,
who began working with protozoa in the 1930s.
Sonneborn developed many of the techniques
that turned paramecia into a model organism,
his work so influential that it has been memorialized
in the name of that 15th P. aurelia subspecies,
P. sonneborni.
While researching paramecia, Sonneborn became
interested in the so-called killer trait,
a subset of paramecia that seemed able to
produce toxins that killed other paramecia.
These killer paramecia all shared a trait:
the presence of mysterious cytoplasmic particles
called kappa.
Sonneborn tracked how these kappa particles
passed on through generations, proposing the
“plasmagene theory” to explain the patterns
he saw, a hypothesis that these kappa particles
were some special thing coded in the paramecium’s
DNA, but that could self-replicate on their
own in the cytoplasm.
And he was wrong.
It turned out that these kappa particles aren’t
particles, they are bacteria: another example
of endosymbiosis, except that instead of providing
the nourishing promise of photosynthesis,
these bacteria turned their paramecium homes
into killers.
It took time for Sonneborn to accept that
his plasmagene theory didn’t explain kappa particles.
But if paramecia have come to model so much
of what we learn in science, then looking
more broadly, this microscopic organism also
models us and our own use of the scientific process.
In a letter to another researcher, Sonneborn
reflected on this, on what it means to set
aside his own ego for the reality of the microbe,
to know that studying nature requires an understanding
of our own selves.
He wrote, “‘It was awful of me to be so
attached to a pet idea.
That was an ordeal between my mind and my
heart and it took a while for the mind to
win and the heart to accept.
Impersonal scientific objectivity is a goal
to be sought by hard self-discipline; we are
not born with it.’’
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Journey to the Microcosmos is produced by
Complexly.
We produce over a dozen different shows, including
a new one, Ours Poetica, it’s a co-production
between Complexly, The Poetry Foundation,
and the poet Paige Lewis.
Ours Poetica brings you a new poem three times
a week, read by poets, writers, artists, and
sometimes unexpected, yet familiar, voices
like... like mine for example.
You can check out a video of me reading Edgar
Alan Poe's "The Raven".
We think there are times for YouTube to be
high energy and times for it to be a little
bit more relaxing.
Journey to the Microcosmos and Ours Poetica
are both going for that second thing.
I also want to say thank you for listening
to my extra gravely voice today.
I have a cold.
We haven’t talked much about viruses on
this channel.
They are very difficult to observe, they’re
tiny, probably aren’t really even alive.
But they have colonized much of my upper respiratory
system right now and I’m just pushing through.
Also thank you so much to everyone who has
signed up to be one of our patrons on Patreon.
We are extremely grateful to be able to make
this content and you are the reason why we
get to.
And if you want to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James, check out Jam and Germs
on Instagram.